welcome back to the five live from
Nashville let's get to some news pramas
lunatics causing Anarchy outside the
[Applause]
DNC at least six officers injured after
150 Israel hating agitators stormed the
DNC headquarters and blocked the doors
protesters calling themselves peaceful
as they flung fists and pepper sprayed
cops the chaos causing Democrats inside
to evacuate and house offices to be
locked down so far only one arrest and
the insanity continued today one of the
Rabid protesters confronting the
Democrat who called their Antics Pro
terrorist sir sir sir what is the
strategy to Sir what is the strategy to
do that there is no I've got to get your
organization to call for Hamas to disarm
that's my Netanyahu just stop saying
that they're going to raise Goda to the
ground and that they're fighting Human
animals the anti-israel leftist also
blocking traffic today on bridges in
Boston and in San Francisco during rush
hour well you know how I feel about
traffic judge what should happen there
well I got to tell you you've got six
cops injured uh according to the capital
police 150 people acting illegally and
one person is arrested okay and here's
here's here's a gem for you they brought
out the National Guard on Tuesday for
the Israeli Peace uh March where there
was no violence at all no one got
arrested but to me this is just
Wednesday in Biden's America all right
the sad part about all of this is that
they're calling for a deescalation
they're calling for you know a decrease
in the violence we want to ceasefire and
they're doing it violently so I mean it
makes no sense it's just contradictory
to everything that that they're supposed
to to be doing but that's just Le and
the squad and what they believe in
Jessica your part is running wild what
do you have to say for
yourself we've talked about this before
that is not my party so I'm sure some do
vote for Democrats and members of the
squad did come out and defend it and say
this was their right to peacefully
protest and the ones who were peacefully
protesting that's a prerogative but
that's not what was going on there I a
don't know what they thought they were
going to accomplish at the DNC it's just
like a weird location to to go and do
this and I think the juxtaposition of
the 290,000 people who were at the March
for Israel completely peaceful who all
went through the mags checked in right
stood there and listened to speeches for
hours and then you see this you know
just a couple days later was quite Stark
um I wasn't on the show right after the
March resal so I just wanted to say that
I found all the speeches very powerful
but in particular from hearing from the
families who also spoke about the
innocent Palestinian lives this is not
something that is lost on people that
there are innocent people on the other
side of this but a ceasefire is a win
for Hamas and that's just not happening
do you understand the fact Tyrus that
only one person was arrested after that
kind of behavior unfortunately I do
understand that and we all understand it
because and probably that person was out
by the afternoon you know the difference
between the two groups is belief and
passion because if I care about
something and I want peace I'm going to
push it I'm going to be the biggest
monstrous peaceful man because if I
promote peace maybe they will too but
these marches aren't about the
Palestinians these marches about what we
just saw they want the police to engage
with them they want the violence you can
never have a mostly peaceful protest if
the five of us are up here and we're all
peacefully protesting and Dana decides
to throw something it's no longer a
peaceful protest and we all should look
at her and be like this is why you don't
get to
drink I know I didn't get I mean and and
I I make a joke but that's the point and
it's the same protest we saw with black
lives mattered it's a professional
protest designed to engage to get police
officers to attack them so they get the
video clip now we're talking about it as
it happens you take the sounds out and
you get a documentary behind it or you
get the right Network behind it and
they'll talk about brutality as they
fought for the Palestinian children the
evil Police Department Department of
America is attacking them and that's all
they're there for it's the same
individuals and if you ever stop them
and say what are you here for they'll
say no you're a racist I'm here to stop
you and they have no idea what they're
talking about and that's and that's the
sadness of it all that's the difference
between the two Dana Pino well I I have
two things one is I think that all of
those protesters would last about 18
minutes under islamist rule MH okay all
of them would have been arrested and
more for that behavior the other thing
is something very strange is going on at
the Washington Post they had almost
300,000 people arrive on the National
Mall completely piece 300,000 the
largest March for Israel in the history
of the United States and it doesn't even
meet the a section of the Washington
Post it's buried in the metro section
fine section whatever but that's where
you bury that news then you have 150 Pro
attacking the DNC this is the heart of
Washington DC and it doesn't make the
front page of the paper like something
very strange is going on but we are
paying attention we're paying attention
especially Dana who never misses
anything coming up from Music City
uhoh even Joe Biden doesn't think he
should be running for president hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else